it's no secret that big tech companies
pay out compensation figures that aren't
comparable to any other industry
Engineers fresh out of college are able
to earn nearly
$200,000 with just a couple of years of
experience they can up that to $300 to
$400,000 and by the time they're in
their 30s they're often earning $500,000
to $1
million these jobs also often come with
a bunch of perks like unlimited paid
time off the ability to work from
anywhere in the world free food stock
and the fastest growing companies and so
on if you ask the average person the
only real downside of working at Big
Tech is that there may be some level of
moral compromise I mean at this point
it's really no secret how a lot of these
companies make money even when it's not
straight up data collection or privacy
intrusion it's often monopolization
anti-consumer policies and abusing of
power but this moral dilemma and quote
unquote selling out is only the tip of
the iceberg this is actually often the
least of your concerns when it comes to
surviving and advancing at Big Tech the
reality is that despite their inviting
looking offices and seemingly employee
friendly policies working at Big Tech is
much more like being a professional
athlete if you follow Sports you'll
often hear about contracts that are
worth tens of millions if not hundreds
of millions of dollars but actually
cashing in on the full value of these
contracts is much easier said than done
usually half or more of these contracts
are paid out based on performance and
unless you're a able to keep up
worldclass performance for 5 to 10 years
straight you're only going to walk away
with a fraction of the Topline value
it's not that dissimilar at Big Tech you
get paid Sky High salaries but you're
also expected to perform at worldclass
levels the moment that you don't you're
cut from the team and this isn't
speculation or anecdotal either you can
go on to Netflix's official company
culture page and you'll see them say
quote we model ourselves on being a
professional sports team not a family a
dream team is about pushing yourself to
be the best possible teammate caring
intensely about your team and knowing
that you may not be on the team forever
dream teams are about performance not
seniority or tenure it is up to the
manager to ensure that every player is
amazing at their position plays
effectively with others and is given new
opportunities to develop that's how we
keep winning the championship so here's
the truth about working at Big
Tech
out of all the big tech companies the
company with the most Cutthroat
environment is no doubt Netflix and
before we discuss the inner workings of
Netflix I wanted to clarify that I'm not
trying to paint any of these companies
in a bad light Netflix for example is
often the most generous of any company
in the entire world when it comes to
compensation you know those multi six
figure and seven figureure contracts you
hear about at Big tech company companies
well most of them are largely made up of
stock comp and bonuses at Netflix
however the entire comp is purely cash
so it's no wonder why they expect so
much and I'm not criticizing that by any
means rather I want to show how working
at these companies is often not as rosy
as you might think and that there is
definitely a price to pay with that
being said let's jump into the Netflix
pressure cooker starting with their
policy of extreme openness and quote
unquote radical transparency
at most companies compensation and
performance is something that is
discussed behind closed doors with just
your boss and maybe your boss's boss
this is designed to minimize conflicts
between employees regarding compensation
and keep performance reviews private at
Netflix however it's the exact opposite
everyone who is a director or above has
access to the salaries of not just their
direct reports but everyone at the
entire company and as for performance
reviews these are even more accessible
everyone one who is an admin or up has
access to the performance reviews of
everyone at the entire organization
you're probably thinking that this would
lead to a lot of awkward conversations
you know the whole always knowing how
your peers are performing and how much
they're earning and that they know the
same about you but that's kind of the
point Netflix hopes that by making this
information widely accessible it
encourages employees to constantly
improve to survive for example if you
know that you're the worst performing
director while getting paid the most you
know that it's time to step the hell up
unless you want to be cut next quarter
and believe me Netflix does not think
twice when it comes to firing people and
no one is safe which brings us into the
keeper test Netflix encourages their
management to constantly evaluate
whether they would rehire Andor fight
for their direct reports if the answer
is ever no it's time to fire them and
don't think that you can be the chill
manager that doesn't do this either if
you're the chill manager you'll come off
as being soft then soon find yourself on
the chopping block because like I said
No One Is Safe And this applies to even
sea level Executives if you've been a
Netflix subscriber for a while you
probably remember how garbage their
recommendation algorithm was back in the
mid-20s some of you would argue that
it's still garbage but it has gotten a
lot better and that's thanks to the
keeper test in 2017 after receiving a
bunch of negative feedback about
curation Netflix decided to fire their
chief prodct officer that was
responsible for the curation algorithm
Neil hunt this was despite Neil being a
personal friend of Reed Hastings and an
OG employee who had been there since
1999 and that was a rather soft
sacrifice in mid 2021 Netflix fired
three Marketing Executives at the same
time for not conforming to the company's
policy of radical transparency for
perspective that was half of their
entire executive marketing team as you
can see Netflix does not hold back but
at least Netflix is completely
transparent about that they're Cutthroat
and they're proud about it the same
however cannot be said about their big
Tech peers who often use much more
underhanded
[Music]
tactics the king of underhanded tactics
is none other than Amazon who very much
has a culture of churn because that's
how boss Bezos likes it in fact Bezos
isn't a big fan of tenur employees
because he thinks that people simply get
more comfortable and lazier with time
leading to a march to mediocrity as such
Amazon has a bunch of policies to
constantly turn through employees
starting with pips or performance
Improvement plans every year Amazon has
a policy of firing the bottom 10% of
their Workforce this way the quality of
their Workforce is always theoretically
improving in reality this often just
leads to a bunch of toxicity office
politics and bad blood in fact in fact
it's common practice for Amazon managers
to hire to fire which is exactly what it
sounds like if you're an Amazon manager
with a solid team it's common to hire
someone just so that you can fire them
at the end of the year and preserve your
core team this also works perfectly with
Amazon's compensation structure which
only pays out the majority of the stock
comp in the third and fourth years so
Amazon is able to get away with paying
much less to employees who get turned
out but coming from Amazon I don't think
any of that is really surprising what
may be surprising however is the various
tactics that Google and Facebook employ
unlike Amazon or Netflix Google and
Facebook are much more Sly in their
approach as they like to come off as the
good guy as such they tend to employ
good cop strategies for example the main
reason that Google serves free breakfast
lunch and dinner is not because they
love feeding everyone great food but to
maximize
unproductivity if great food is served
on campus it's less likely that people
will go out for lunch in fact it's
likely that a lot would simply work
through lunch or at least spend a lot
less time at lunch also the timing of
free food is position to increase the
length of the workday for example Google
doesn't start serving dinner till 6:30
to 8:00 p.m. as such if you come into
work at 8:00 a.m. and want a partake in
free dinner you can easily find yourself
at work from 8:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. it's
the same reason why Google offers or at
least used to offer perks like free
massages haircuts and pingpong tables
all of these perks were designed to keep
you at the office for as long as
possible and hopefully work for as long
as possible even more employee friendly
policies like unlimited paytime off have
even darker realities when a company
offers unlimited paytime off employees
feel a lot more guilty when taking days
off in fact the average employee with
unlimited paytime off only takes 11 days
off per year while the average employee
with limited paytime off takes off 17
days and that's just what you see at
first glance it turns out that 42% of
employees with unlimited paytime off
actually end up working even during
their vacation days and it gets even
worse when you have limited PTO and you
don't use all of it you have the ability
to cash out this PTO when you leave it
even if it's because you got fired with
unlimited PTO though there is no
acquired PTO meaning that there's
nothing to cash out when you leave even
though you barely took any vacation they
hire the most talented and competitive
people in the world and they dangle the
opportunity to have even more power
money and influence in front of them I
think you can guess what sort of
environment this would lead to which
brings us into the truth about big Tech
culture as you can see Netflix has the
whole professional athlete model Amazon
has the churn model and Google and
Facebook have the good cop model but if
this is the reality of working at Big
Tech why do we never hear about this
even more than that why do we always
hear about these companies being the
best places in the world to work well
this has a lot to do with selection bias
and a great analogy for this is AP
testing if you're not familiar with AP
exams it's what a lot of American High
School students take to earn college
credit the lowest score on the test is a
one and the highest score is a five and
one of the AP subjects with the lowest
fire rates is physics 1 with only 8% of
students getting a five 27% of students
actually get the lowest score A1 this
isn't all that surprising given that
physics is an extremely tough subject
you know what is surprising though one
of the AP subjects with the highest five
rates is physics C&M a much harder and
more advanced physics class 31% of test
takers get a five on physics C&M and
only 12% get a one a subject with even
better five rates is Calculus BC where a
whopping 42% of test takers get a five
and only 6% get a one
does this mean that physics C and
Calculus BC are way easier than physics
1 of course not it's just that only
super smart people take these advanced
classes in the first place and they end
up doing really well it's the same thing
with these big tech companies it's not
that these jobs are actually super chill
and pay super well they're actually
hyper competitive and extremely keen on
ensuring that you earn your salary but
only extremely talented hyper
competitive individuals who thrive in
this sort of environment or actually
higher to begin with as such big Tech is
actually much more comparable to other
high pressure Fields like Investment
Banking and hedge funds as opposed to
normal companies who happen to hire
software engineers and this is the
reality that is often lost when
discussing careers at Big Tech like with
any industry the payout is proportional
to the expectations with something like
Finance the high expectations are
evident to everyone you have to
outperform the market something that 90%
of from managers fail to do with tech
however the high expectations aren't as
evident from the outside but believe me
there is no free launch at Big Tech both
literally and figuratively and that is
the true price of working at Big Tech at
least these companies pay massive
salaries to compensate for that oh wait
never mind they're making moves to
dramatically decrease pay check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one